first up tonight white house
correspondent peter ducey live on the
north lawn good evening peter good
evening brett a president who once
promised to put away the harsh rhetoric
and lower the temperature is not doing
that instead today accusing the minority
in the senate of being too stubborn to
help the majority raise the debt limit
by the middle of this month
their obstruction and their
responsibility knows absolutely no
bounds if the u.s defaults on debt
payments the president says blame
republicans they need to stop playing
russian roulette with the u.s economy
republicans say that's backwards
democrats need to tackle the debt limit
we gave them a road map
and three months notice biden argues he
just got here these bills aren't his
raising the debt limit
is about paying off our old debts
there's nothing to do with any new
spending being considered that's nothing
to do with my plan for infrastructure
or building back better zero
zero
both of which i might add are paid for
how does that work you can pay for it
either by borrowing it or you can pay
for it by raising taxes on corporations
and the wealthy but it doesn't cost zero
at the end of the day it will cost zero
because we're going to pay for it that's
some tricky math does the plan cost
nothing or is the plan free
the plan costs nothing for the american
people who make less than four hundred
thousand dollars speaker pelosi says
votes on that plan can wait till
halloween i need 50 votes
in the senate
i have 48. the two dems not on board joe
manchin who was greeted at his houseboat
by kai activists we all love our state
too much to see it go by the wayside and
kirsten cinema hounded by protesters in
a ladies room she now says it is the
duty of elected leaders to avoid
fostering an environment in which
honestly held policy disagreements serve
as the basis for vitriol raising the
temperature in political rhetoric and
creating a permission structure for
unacceptable behavior fox news asked the
president about these progressive
protesters do you think that those
tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them um so it's it's part of the
process
part of the process and since president
biden is an expert on the process i
asked his press secretary jensaki today
if that means that he has ever been
chased into a restroom by activists she
didn't answer that part but did
reiterate they think that behavior in
the restroom with senator cinema is
unacceptable however she reiterated the
president's support for the fundamental
right to protest brett well have senator
cinema or mansion reacted to president
biden's remark about the efforts to go
after them part of the process not since
president biden made that comment late
this morning and we have laid eyes on
them senator manchin is already back on
the hill he talked about some policy
things and his thoughts on
infrastructure didn't mention uh the kai
activists senator cinema meanwhile there
is some footage
bubbling up on social media in the last
few minutes arriving at washington
reagan national airport hounded by
protesters she didn't say anything but
they're obviously not done with her yet
part of the process right peter ducey
live in the north lawn peter thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else